[Music]
just wanted to
work a little bit through responsible ml
journey within microsoft
but with a focus on the two packages
that i'm driving the product efforts
um within azure ai and microsoft
research
as a joint collaboration which are as
krishna
kindly mentioned interpret ml and
fairlearn we are all here
because we care about responsible ai but
why responsibility in general
something that i really liked from the
book tools and weapons that really talks
about how
microsoft president batsmead really
thinks about responsible
ai is the more powerful the tool the
greater the benefit or damage it can
cause
so of course with any impact that you're
having in people's lives
it really comes the responsibility of
not
how to use it but where to use your
power and
how to affect people's lives um so
responsibly ai we are pretty much seeing
it
as a real challenge for many of our
customers
um as as also it was reported in
capgemini report that
uh with reporting nine out of ten
executives
across the whole globe so it's like as
you can see a global
study that they've done and it was
reported that nearly nine out of ten
executives have reported
facing with some form of ethical issues
when it comes to implementation
or deployment of ai so there are so many
reasons that they cited in this study
but among them
the executives cited reasons including
the pressure to urgently implement ai
the failure to consider ethics when
constructing ai systems
and really lack of access to practical
tools to ensure that the ai is being
developed and deployed
responsibly so we saw that as an
opportunity to come up with
um of course tools that are really also
considering the socio-technical aspect
and hence i'm highlighting two of them
in
our today's presentation now taking a
step back
let's see how the responsible ai journey
started within the company now
almost near four years ago a satya
nadellar ceo
um basically penned an article in the
slate magazine that was titled
uh the partnership of the future and in
this article
introduced concepts of transparency
efficiency etc
but not at the expense of dignity of
people
intelligent privacy algorithmic
accountability and protection against
bias
i would say about a year or shortly
after
we formed our ii ethics committee which
is called ether
and it's short for ai ethics and effect
in engineering and research which has
many different working groups underneath
each of these working groups are
focusing on one particular
concept maybe fairness transparency
sensitive use cases security etc
and of course ethers spend a lot of time
listening to customer
internal experts and then partner with
legal affairs to
publish the future computed in january
and then microsoft called for a lot of
regulations and
specifically in the space of facial
recognition in july 2018
and uh the principle published around
december 2018
and around 2019 office of responsible ai
within microsoft bus form
and uh published a set of internal
standards for responsible ai that
internal teams basically should very
very closely
follow when they want to develop or
deploy artificial intelligence systems
now to put our principles into practice
we've also developed a set of tools to
help others understand protect and
control their ai at every stage of
innovation
our results are basically these tools a
lot of them are available externally
like ai business school has a lot of
great resources that you absolutely
should check if you haven't
and they're really aligned with both
data science concepts but also
how to develop and deploy ai systems
responsibly
the office of responsible ai also has a
public-facing website with
many many great practical tools and
tutorials and case studies regarding the
responsible ai
so i really recommend you taking a look
at the office of response ai page as
well
and eventually um the the messaging that
we
announced at parkers of field about a
month or two month ago
was really three different buckets that
we would like to make sure we have
practical tools for
and one is understand to basically
understand your ml life cycle
better then protect how to make sure
that of course data is not just data
data is representing people how to make
sure that the data is
confidential of the ml uh pipeline
and the confidentiality of uh many many
different machine learning problems and
twenty
is is uh staying um completely true and
and hidden from the eyes of either a
hacker or even
internal people data scientists etc who
are not supposed to access those type of
information
uh directly things like eyes off
training etc and also control how to
make sure that
people have are held accountable
end-to-end for training models can
control their
path can audit their path can monitor
their path etc
so the focus of today call is mostly on
the understand bucket
and um the understand bucket is really
well aligned with
some aspects of the or a lot of aspects
of the ai principles that we have in
place and by no means this microsoft ai
principles is the ground truce or
anything i'm sure
every single company that you are from
has its own set of ai principles that is
wonderful
and is being practiced internally but
within microsoft
these are the set of uh ai principles
that we believe should really inform the
development and deployment of ai system
in a responsible way and those are
fairness reliability and safety privacy
and security inclusiveness
underpinned by two foundational ones uh
transparency and accountability
and first i'm gonna start with uh
basically
transparency and interpretability and
i'll share my slides you can
take a look at our oss website the
tutorial video
customer highlight in order for you to
see how interpret ml has been used in an
end-to-end customer
customer use case but we introduced a
tool called
interpret ml less than a year ago and
if you check out interpret.ml it's going
to take you to a landing page
the goal of it is really to
understanding and debugging models
and and the biggest uh value prop behind
it is
we work with many customers from a
specifically heavy regulated space
and we realize that one of the biggest
challenges that they have is
one they have a hard time proving that
their model is doing what it's supposed
to do based on the signals that it makes
sense rather than problematic patterns
to their non-technical stakeholders or
business stakeholders etc
they also have a hard time to audit
their models to understand
what went wrong inside the model and how
to improve it
and take the next steps uh to take it to
the next level
and last but not least they wanted a way
to ensure that the model is making its
decisions
based on roughly fair insights and is
not considering the sensitive attributes
of people
as a hugely important signal to make its
predictions
so they had no way of really having
these signals without interpretability
toolkits
and then taking a step back so far
everything that i have
focused on about interpretability is
really about interpretability and
training time
but taking a step back even at scoring
time or inferencing time
people put out the model up there they
put it out there and then they have no
idea how the model is impacting people's
lives in the real world so of course
when you
put the model out there you bear this
responsibility to provide them with a
lot of
why answers right they come to you and
they ask why my
model has got rejected you should have
this
insight as um oh based on
this signal that signal that signal the
model has provided
this particular decision to your use
case and when you think about
gdpr's right to explanation that is also
talking about the same concept as
whoever's legal status is being affected
by an ai system
at scoring time right in french in time
has the right to go and ask why
and this for instance one of these
toolkits are supposed to provide you
with also interpretability
insights at scoring time now
right off the bat when you land on the
interpret.ml and go to the github
there are four different repositories
that you will figure you will see
underneath that and two of them are
mostly for interpretability technique
for tabular data i'll explain what is
included
momentarily then we have expanded it to
nlp scenarios we started with text
classifications a lot more scenarios
will come soon but
also if you have a particular nlp
scenario that needs interpretability
definitely feel free to reach out to me
on linkedin etc and i'll be super happy
to see what we can do for your use cases
then we have dice which is diverse
counter factual explanation which
basically talks about
um who is the closest person to my data
point
which has received a different outcome
from the model
or you can also take a look at it this
way what is the minimum change that
should happen to my data point
in order to make me qualified for the
loan in case i'm rejected right now
and then i'm also going to very briefly
touch on what aspect of it has been
integrated within azure machine learning
so focusing on tabular data
interpretability we cover a collection
of grass box models that are
intrinsically interpretable model
and black box explainers that can
basically sit on top of
any black box model that you have no
matter it's a traditional machine
learning model
or a deep neural network model like
pytorch tensorflow
and keras among our glassbox models uh
we are very proud of explainable
boosting machine or evm
if you check out the interpret with me
you will see that this is a very unique
contribution from microsoft research to
this open source repo
and that's the only uh interpretable
model at the moment
with very very comparable accuracy and
efficiency to
known models like let gbm xg boost etc
but also completely transparent inside
out and very lossless
so it models the interactions between
features it also models a higher degree
of dependence of
output to input features and the idea is
based on general
generalized additive models
among our black box interpretability
techniques we are bringing many
uh proven third-party or microsoft
research interpretability techniques
under one set of api
so you can call all of them compare the
results we do have an
interactive visualization dashboard
where you can see your model performance
you can see your
data exploration and i really briefly
show that to you so basically you can
see your model performance
you can also add cohorts and see your
model performance across different
cohorts for instance like if you want to
have only females only males and see how
the model is treating them
you can look at your data statistics you
can look at
your top k important factors and click
and see
how those factors are impacting your
model prediction
and eventually you can look at
individual future importance or local
explanation click on a particular data
point
look at the local explanation for that
particular decision that the model is
making and
also performing perturbations or what-if
analysis
um these are uh basically built with the
and i'm trying to go back to sorry um so
these are
all available to you within um as i said
uh our open source offering absolutely
for free and i'll talk about
what aspects we have integrated within
azure ml but let's briefly
talk about our fairness offering which
is another open source offering
uh and we call it fairlearn the idea
behind is
behind it is there are many ways that ai
systems can behave
unfairly there's so many type of harm
that ai can give rise to
and two very common one among like many
different types of harm
is harm of quality of service and harm
of allocation
now harm of allocation is where when
your ai system
is withholding or providing
opportunities information or resources
from people
um and uh like one major
example of it is say a models for
screening loan or job application might
be much
better at picking good candidates among
white men
compared to some other groups the other
type that i would like to
highlight is harm of quality of service
where you would receive a different
quality of service from the ai system
only because of your sensitive
attributes and one example of it
can be a voice recognition system might
fail to work as well for women as it
does for men
or another very famous example of it is
facial recognition systems
uh known developed by some very known
companies out there including microsoft
itself
were reported to have lower accuracy
on females with darker skin tones so
this is only because of the fact that
you're a female with darker skin tone
you're receiving a completely different
quality of service from the space
identification system
compared to say a white male so the goal
of this project was really to avoiding
negative outcomes of ai systems for
different groups of people
now i should put a huge disclaimer out
there that uh
fairness is a socio-technical concept
and many
aspects of it like justice and due
process etc cannot even
be understood or measured by ai
first this is a topic that is being
studied by philosophers social
scientists
um psychologists like et cetera et
cetera for decades and centuries and
centuries
so we suddenly can't come from the tech
world and say we have a solution for it
but we believe that there are some
aspects of it when it comes to this
particular two types of harms in our
dataset in our toolkit that we can at
least measure
and we can take steps towards mitigating
that
and that's why our toolkit consists of
two different phases
fairness assessment and we provide
another interactive dashboard that i
momentarily show you
where you pick your sensitive attribute
and then you can measure
at some some different fairness metrics
on top of your
basic demographics that you chose it can
be female versus males it can be
different income groups it can be
different
age groups it can be different races or
ethnicities different sexual orientation
etc
and then after you measure that and you
observe and uncover
some potential fairness issues that are
happening in your model
some potential subgroups that are
negatively impacted by your ai system
you can of course go back all the way to
the beginning of your ml life cycle
observe your data augment and enhance
your data get rid of some trash data and
augment it with better data maybe
represent some
underrepresented groups better etc
and go through your model collection
data collection phase make sure that
it's not introducing some
unfairness go to your model training etc
but as your last hope if you have done
all these things and you're still
observing some fairness issues
we are also providing a set of
state-of-the-art mitigation algorithms
from microsoft research in new york city
as a part of this toolkit where you can
load these
they basically act as a wrapper on top
of your ml
algorithm and call your model rewait or
relabel your data multiple times with
respect a fairness with respect to a
fairness constraint that you pass to
your
mitigation for instance you can say i
want to mitigate unfairness with respect
to demographic parody or equalized odds
or equal opportunity etc etc and there
are multiple events that we support
or say bounded group loss for regression
case and then
based on that criteria that you have
passed to the mitigation algorithm
that goes through the mitigation each
time provides you with a model
and then at the very end of the day you
have a set of models that you can
compare to your
original model uh and you can see that
the performance versus the fairness uh
trade-off there
and as a stakeholder you can choose
which model
is more appropriate for your use case
how much performance is there a
trade-off maybe yes
how much accuracy or performance you can
sacrifice in order to improve
fairness etc and so you in your context
you can decide how to move forward with
this and so the way that it works
is uh basically you you bring your input
and you specify the sensitive attributes
and the performance metric of interest
then you basically go through the
assessment phase and you look at the
disparity in
your performance depending on what type
of performance metric you've selected
the distribution of errors across your
subgroups and also you look at the
disparity
selection rate what percentage of people
have been selected to get the favorable
outcome
and then you can use mitigation
algorithms depending on
how you want to use that whether you are
allowed to touch the machine
learning model or not if yeah if no
post-processing algorithms to sit on top
of your model prediction
if yes then reduction algorithms which
basically goes through the
multiple times of retraining your model
with respect to a fairness constraint
and you can use them in order to
alleviate the
unfairness that you're observing now
we started our team believes in an open
source approach we strongly believe that
responsible ai is a brand new booming
field that is basically needs to be
considered in
every single life cycle whether you're
coming from a heavily regulated space or
not
and because of that vision that we have
it started everything in
in the open source so please feel free
to try it
fairlearn.org interpret.ml are the two
landing pages that we have for these two
toolkits
but in order to empower the customers
and users that we have on azure machine
learning
we also have integrated it within azure
machine learning so basically the way
that it works
is without these uh nodes uh this is how
azure machine learning
uh lifecycle works it has training and
deployment
you you bring in script and then you
execute it on a compute target it can be
a cpu gpu etc after each run
all the run records are going to be
stored in in azure machine learning run
history
which is like a module to save your
model for a
model basically assets and all the
metadata around that
you go back and forth and you take a
look at your model
and maybe to need again or improve your
data etc and go through this life cycle
multiple times until
you feel comfortable about your model
and then you go ahead to the deployment
phase register it create an image and
deploy it
for scoring time and what we are
providing to you is uh we have
incorporated these open source offerings
within azure ml so
as a part of your training you can also
generate explanation and model fairness
insights and you have the functionality
to upload them to azure machine learning
around history
and this way we support interpretability
and fairness as a part of azure machine
learning sdk and studio which is an
um framework or basically a toolkit
visual toolkit that we have
for you to manage all your assets in one
place
and then you go ahead and you register
your model but also you register the
corresponding explainer alongside that
you provide an image or create a docker
image of both and
you deploy both so at scoring time you
can call the deployed
the deployed model get the prediction
but also you can get the deployed
explainers and get the explanations
and this way we're really hoping that um
our customers who are on azure
machine learning can also incorporate
these type of practical tools
actively in their ml life cycle
and yeah this is uh some tools for
the azure machine learning integrations
if you want the open source one
fairlearn.org and interpret.ml
are the links that takes you to the
landing page the user guide and the
github page
you